[Music]
so there are actually uh two long island
nurses who allegedly made
more than 1.5 million dollars by selling
fake vaccination cards saw this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's like half of a board 8 yacht club
there
how much were they selling it for okay
so uh suffolk county district attorney
raymond tierney said the nurses were
charging 220
for forged vaccination cards for adults
and 85 for children in a scheme that
began in november wow dude they sold a
lot they must think we talk we spoke
ourselves up to shout outs to these guys
yeah
suffolk university oh oh you went to
suffolk university okay i thought you
said you spoke to these people shout out
to these people
i was like wait what shout out to the
two long island nurses
the pair of nurses would uh then after
being after charging their clients so to
speak uh enter incorrect information
into new york state immunization
database
which is what would obviously make it
quote-unquote official they allegedly
forward vaccination cards uh
for an undercover detective before being
charged also they do legit fake ones
that's see that's work because it's in
the database it's not just a forged one
yeah they forge it they put the
information down and they put that in
the database so that those are actual
vaccination reports for everybody even
though they're not walking around
vaccinations is the undercover cops one
grandfather didn't
is he is he good
all right
this one's for me and uh this one's for
evidence
for me thank you very much puts it in
his wallet and he's like
i'd like to report a crime
not me though not me not me no no no no
no no oh no these rats i saw this one
nurse
uh where
she would just squirt the vaccine at
them just to kind of go through the
motions and then fill out the card i'm
serious
this idea of my backseat is splashing on
someone stab it because there's a lot of
people that need to travel or their job
or whatever but they don't want the
vaccine so it's like well i'll go
through the motions of it and it's just
people providing these services instead
of actually jabbing they're just like
shhh like that all right
they're just waiting in new york new
york this is new york i would not have
expected new york i would totally expect
new york
all right dish
[ __ ] that's what you know
well they have the craziest mandates
right so it makes sense where where they
can't eat unless yeah where there's the
craziest mandates people are going to
find like this wouldn't happen in
florida
you know what i mean yeah for sure they
don't even need it like 7 000 ish people
how much you think they're paying out in
uh california for fake vaccine cards
what's the highest you pay for a high
for fake vaccines i know a ton of people
legitimately in l.a first and last name
go
how much there's some like russian
doctors that are just like do the
paperwork for you not not jab you
russian doctors i mean there's there is
that in every kind of sector of like the
healthcare right like what would it be
like
whether whether it be like what weed
even like drug tests okay russian
doctors uh handicapped signs for the car
podiatrists
my mom used to do it all the time oh
[ __ ] so like uh mama called your mom
this video is going on patreon no no it
doesn't matter she has a crazy ass uh
uh health benefits from her job back in
the day and my mom this might have to go
on facebook
this is this is how you guys gonna show
up to your mom's house it's covered it
covers her eyes but her eyes aren't bad
and so i had contacts so if you go to
chinese optometrists they already know
what's up so when you go up to them and
you're like hey i have insurance i don't
need it then they'll just bill the
prescription contacts on my mom's thing
that's pretty cool so they still make
money
my mom does have to come out of pocket
and everyone is happy that's robin hood
that's why china is number one
what does china have to do with anything
i don't know because their families are
con artists
yeah clip that
i mean that for sure happens though
right like people be like helping each
other out based off of your ethnicity
all of 626 dude
send the fbi to the san gabriel valley i
know but also it's like dude people have
to do this to get
health care that's kind of weird right
yeah yeah well i mean it's not that
surprising in america is it yeah it's
like holy [ __ ] nope we pay how much out
of like compared to the rest of the
world it's nuts it's crazy dude yeah
it's not fair so uh as nurses these two
individuals should understand the
importance of legitimate vaccination
cards as we all work together to protect
public health says suffolk county police
commissioner rodney harrison and uh the
one of the
nurses lawyers i guess said that the
that nurse was a well-respected nurse
and encouraged people to take caution
when forming judgments about the
situation
well that's a really she took the bribe
and she goes be careful
or maybe that's more of a uh
after you get caught it's like hey don't
judge me too harshly think about how
like complicated this dude you're like
getting blown by a hooker in your hotel
room and your wife walks in like this is
not what it looks like
i'm a well-respected guy
i'm a nurse i'm a member of the
well-respected hooker
law enforcement
900 thousand dollars
law enforcement sees nine hundred
thousand dollars in cash whoa so they
were saving it yeah and a ledger
revealing illegal profits of over one
point five million from their home
profits too not even wow and this person
said i hope this sends a message to
others who are considering gaming the
system that they will get caught and
that we will enforce the law to the
fullest experience there's
a lot of people doing this all over
for sure we hope this sends a message
that this is an extremely profitable
enterprise it's a cash rich business
and we want to show that we caught two
people thank you it is fairly easy to
perform this operation
you're actually doing less by making
this money by the way this is one of
those things where you put the
information out in news and then
suddenly everybody gets like a copy yeah
it's stupid yeah 220 dollars about the
amount of money
they should they should have i think
they have the ledger though everybody's
always got to track it right it's like
your serial killer that has to have
evidence for everything yeah
maybe they're chinese they're yeah
they're accountants
well i mean remember the [ __ ] all
these scams that were happening with
like ppp uh and sba loans and stuff like
that yeah they're gonna go after those
like little by little yeah you still
think so i think so because that's one
thing the government doesn't give up on
is getting money it's owed to them
they're not gonna just stop doing i
think we lost like
either a billion or multi multi-millions
of uh dollars in the scams from uh what
do you call it those [ __ ] checks
those yeah no no just those stimulus
checks yeah or like what do you mean
because like a bunch of things you were
getting 1200
a bunch of people in jail are getting
them yeah and then like people but it
was going out of the country because um
overseas scammers yeah they were
figuring out ways to register u.s
citizens and then they would funnel the
money out whoa yeah i just like to
elaborate i just like how anthony's
ryan's like oh yeah they're gonna
government's gonna get you those people
doing those fake loans they're gonna get
you and anthony's like oh oh you think
so
i was like he's like
are you sure
i didn't realize that yeah he's like oh
oh really i think they're still
like i'm the [ __ ] guy i'm the one
that's like running the investigation
everybody follows our business you
already know we didn't get enough money
just like they went after people they
accidentally paid too much money do did
you ever see that the government
accidentally paid too much too much
money for the uh
yeah for the stimulus or pv and they
just got called way later and be like
hey you got to pay that money back no
what do you do what do you do though
when you're like uh used it already yeah
we use it to get into costco what do you
want to do give it back because it's
like one of those things where like the
atm gives you too much money you by law
have to give it back i didn't put a lien
on you that's [ __ ] so now like a
portion of whatever new income you make
has to go to that first i mean weren't
you supposed to call them back and say
hey uh there's too many zeros what the
[ __ ] bro
when does that ever work just can we
zoom in on anthony this whole video
anthony just sweating just
you gotta kill ryan i'm like i'm like
really ryan no they do that we gotta get
rid of him he walks through the door
he's like i think lunch is here he locks
the door he's like no one's leaving this
[ __ ] world
give me the cards give me the cards on
all the cards
all your [ __ ] phones don't text
anybody we're a brotherhood we're
buddies but but were we all the careful
boys remember like when we were the
careful boys together it doesn't matter
now everybody's phone's on airplane mode
right
so funny serious production yeah you
really think so
no no you know
you